as a kid growing up we walk into a
restaurant and they would be like older
woman that could be a grandmother
running like a restaurant like data
centers looks like she had like a stink
attitude what do you want
uh-huh what the one you want a party
yuan Jun so you want when you think
about New York Street food you think
Pizza pretzels and hot dogs but why
aren't we talking about the Jamaican
beef patty you find them everywhere
piece of spots hot dog cart slow Degas
and of course bakeries in any Caribbean
neighborhood but if you think a patty is
a patty as a patty you're dead wrong
we're in New York City my stomping
grounds and there's no shortage of
passion opinions the short answer to
what a Jamaican patty is would be it's
an eternal it's a snack it's a hand food
you undergo you want something you can't
wait for that hidden food and that's
just that's the first incomplete line
you can have to like this one should
biker party if it's good the crumbs must
fall when I was a young reporter
covering Brooklyn one of the great
stories of that era would sort of be a
great Caribbean migration to Brooklyn in
those years in 1970 there were about a
hundred thousand non-hispanic immigrants
from the Caribbean and by 2000 it was
close to 600,000 so that people started
various businesses in some ways almost
as a side hustle and then gradually
those things took over and became
enormous I mean you know the patties in
New York is a big deal for my friend DJ
Clark Kent there's no middle ground
not for hip hop not for sneakers
definitely not for beef patties the
right way is the Brooklyn way aka the
Jamaican mom-and-pop bakery way
[Music]
how do you eat your APA a beef patty is
will be patty there's no such thing as a
mile-deep patty if you get a grandmother
to make it she doesn't make it mousy
fatties are supposed to be one thing on
the plain cross Swan Donnell
I could rock this 250 having somebody's
grandmother back there my friend Clark
here is such a purist
he doesn't even believe that a veggie
patty or a mild patty as a real patty
he's right I mean I'm scared to even ask
but what about cracking it open layering
it with cheese for molds and I know
pepperoni taking it in a pizza oven that
of these patty you go to a pizza shop to
buy beef patty you're a dummy
they're going to buy manufactured ones
that are frozen put them in aa they make
them hot add cheese to make it their own
no it's a [ __ ] out of it that's not a
beef patty that's an abomination of some
[ __ ] that Caribbean came up with first
as soon as you disrespect my culture I
have no love for it have you ever had
one absolutely not and I never will you
know what because I'm Caribbean and I'm
true to live when you're in Midtown and
you see a hotdog cart and there's like
the hotdog in the murky water there's
also the picture of the beef patty who's
ordering that pain trash buyers like a
dude who goes to Canal Street to buy
jewelry
he's a trash buyer yeah but that's also
part of the New York Attorney people are
continued are those that came out of
heat I would have no they want the care
drive in tracking the poor bedraggled
beaten down horns the [ __ ] in front
of them for the whole ride
what about this concept that by having a
beef patty in the bodega
at the pizza shop that's actually
spreading urban culture to masses is
spreading the gentrification helped the
Romanian culture let's say the family
that started Holden quest for cows don't
you think that they want that mask
gentrification because that tonight this
success is money I get that yeah but
then you you lose all of the stuff that
made it good in the first place because
you're not making it the same me
personally if I couldn't find a real one
and it was for golden crust great idea
cereal Clark is one of those beef patty
purist but you can't deny those golden
crust awning are everywhere some of the
proliferation of patty may very well be
due to the entrepreneurial skill of the
people who run the large companies there
are 122 golden crust locations around
the country and if you ask CEO Lowell
Hawthorne the mainstreaming of bran
Jamaica is just getting started
everybody is my competition McDonald is
my competition subway is a competitor
today the Golden Cross patties are
injured military the penal systems New
York City school systems and of course
33 countries we are close to a billion
bean serve the beef patty has
infiltrated every day New York Life in
other ways too if I walk into any bodega
in any neighborhood in the city I'm
going to find a Jamaican patty in the
cold cuts case that's where New Yorkers
find their common ground that's where
the patty does too
[Music]
I'm hearing so much I got credit you
know how much of a hood legend you gotta
be to have yo you got my credit $10 what
I bought what is it come on see for
people who don't live in New York
yes I understand how whatever religion
it is they think it's not to me not this
place raise me that guy right here know
me since I was six years old you know
this is why I could let them feed me and
not pay it back that's that's kind of
like the relationship you have with your
bar they get is the cornerstone of where
we come from yeah this is home yes Oh
literally home where you feel the most
comfortable most comfortable trust
everybody everybody and they know your
order
what am I get you something I mean you'd
be Patty's fellow I'm the same guy but I
just happen to be one in the back of a
phantom I work hard why not this also
has to do with like I mean how did you
get this hashtag the hood Anthony
Bourdain Anthony Bourdain was always the
Idol to me so when I started making my
you know money I was like man I want to
start trying all these things and start
expanding my palate but I still eat
patties and I still need chopped cheese
and a handy that the bodega so I'm like
Anthony Bourdain for the hood I could
show guys from my neighborhood like hey
we can go to mr. Chau where you can try
squid and order things you another child
but we still come back and be
comfortable in our skin you know you'll
have to change who you are okay so now
we are pulling my barbershop smell of a
shop you like these guys are the same
guys in order to be patty of the block
send the kid whoever get a haircut yo
you next you want to be quick go give me
a big fatty I'll cut your neck all the
people that you love
yes tenebris do that in support networks
they don't all look just like you it's a
melting pot you know the cultural divide
is right there in the beef patty right
it's a Caribbean thing but everybody
over here is be fabulous you black
Spanish white Indian rebe pence
that's what makes the beef patty kind of
like a conduit to the cultural little
spots like the hood right if it's not a
bodega or pizzeria I'm not gonna be fat
like it's just not it
just locked away from where upscale
vandal and I shared Patty and a phantom
is the home base of power Isle where
unspoken rival golden crust is all about
self branding how are Isles has made is
marked by infiltrating bed other New
York icon the pizza spot they started
out as a very small family operation and
so they took a big risk and they took
out a loan from the Small Business
Administration opened up a much bigger
factory but now they had to move all
those patties and so they went to
somebody that I'd never heard of before
they called him a jobber and he started
buying laws to go into the pizzas to us
it was almost a metaphor if these pizza
places that would take it to make him
beef patty they would split it open with
a knife they would sprinkle in
mozzarella cheese put it in the pizza
oven melted and serve it and in no time
- got us into all the pizza stores in
New York City suddenly they had people
who were from all over the place for
eating beef patties who wouldn't have
necessarily known about it so is the
pizza fatty and abomination or an
evolution I knew I'd get a real reaction
from my girl Judd Nick a flatfish native
who somehow has never tried one of
[Music]
Oakland Kansas license like just as much
a sample of being from Brooklyn as the
patty is so a pizza Patty's just an
amalgamation of the same thing you see
happening the real fatty spots close
early so like patties like the first
thing you run out of at the bakery so if
you have patties after you know 1 2
o'clock you gotta have a monopoly on the
system how many patties are you selling
a day so quads 24 in a box
who are you selling this use automation
plastic likeness pepperoni cheese sought
to disease sometimes in a wedding all
right right now we're going to dig into
genetics first ever keep on a pizza
patty this is delicious
just go serving it to mostly Caribbean
people it's still us and it's still us
it's a custom order pin it's an American
it's a Brooklyn thing it's a New York
thing we came here to live and be around
other people and if an Italian piece of
[ __ ] week is placed on their menu for
Jamaican beef patty that's a good thing
it's like my baby so sweet honey I don't
go in there and go culture Walter och
you feel it for me like nas it's just
like thank you for having Patty at 2:00
a.m. because I'm starting that isn't a
watered-down Caribbean experience no
because they don't even know we exist
what do people know about the island
nothing you don't even know islands
outside of Jamaica and a food is like
the easiest way to do that and you don't
need to talk so much you know what I
mean and I like the idea like a kid in
Berlin knowing about to be fed with
delicious it's a great thing people come
to New York should be in the Caribbean
community unless you know of it already
you're not going to see it in the time
as much or you might see it every few
years like oh like new Caribbean trains
we just figured out oxtail exists like
and that's just because someone went
like further is a safari even less than
I don't want to be an exotic experience
I want it to be as American as XYZ my
thing is can you take the Jamaican beef
patty out of context or is where you
have one as important as what's in it if
you want I'm here you really don't get
it
okapi in LA for two months I could be in
Miami but I know that when I come back
here and I get a beef patty with cheese
and go to this period I almost feel home
the imagine today that by a cetera
they're kind of muscled into like the
fast-food pantheon of visit people eat
all the time
when you start talking about classic New
York streets who I think the patty is on
its way
[Music]